Bryan Cranston was in New York yesterday
he came by after yesterday's show and he
was so much fun to hang out with he
stayed for about 30-40 minutes and we
talked about a variety of things
obviously sports his career and of
course Breaking Bad here's Bryan
Cranston what do you get walking down
the street somebody says something to
you hey Heisenberg always yeah I get the
Heisenberg a lot even though you don't
look like him well you don't get how for
Malcolm in the middle because that would
be the view that would be the look not
so much anymore but you know what I had
a porter in a airport one time he looked
at me and goes I know you you you the
dad from Malcolm X Malcolm X I go I'm in
Malcolm annua Malcolm X Malcolm X but so
you get that normally though they want
to know about Breaking Bad what about
Breaking Bad a lot about that some
Seinfeld you know and then you know I
get that a lot like an anti den tight
you know so I get some of that and then
I get a little bit of hell but mostly
mostly Breaking Bad III told the dance
though to wanted to further appreciate
Walter to watch you as how and malcolm
in the middle' how tough was it to get
them to believe you could be that kind
of character you know the audition
process there if I had a very lucky
break I had got a job as a guest star on
x-files and the writer producer at that
on that episode happened to be Vince
Gilligan and that was 10 years before
Malcolm in the Middle
so I did the just the job I go off I do
Malcolm in the Middle
Malcolm stopped shooting we're done for
our seven-year run and up comes this
thing it says a guy knows you Vince
Gilligan you worked with him and I go
yeah I don't know I don't know how that
is this is well he wants to see you for
a thing called Breaking Bad
what does that mean it's a colloquialism
he's a nice Virginia gentleman and so I
and I read this and it's phenomenal and
it worked out but only because he was my
champion too to get that role because
they they were saying what the goofy dad
from Malcolm to play Walter White no I
don't that's that's not a good idea but
when you read that was there an episode
that made you like score him a little
bit like that
are we going too far with this or could
Walter go too far on Breaking Bad you
know it was held in such gentle hands by
Vince he a ganache Dover every second of
that thing in fact it whenever he
directed our show and he was asked a
question and he was wondering
specifically he would literally tap his
forehead like is that is that the right
thing and but do I have it all do I have
it all you know and he woulda ghen eyes
over there and you know the color if if
Skylar's toenail polish is red he would
agonize over what shade of red it was
like oh my god I mean to that point it
was and that's why it became what it is
because of his attention to detail how
important was comedy to be inserted in
Breaking Bad it was really important in
the beginning you'll see there was more
of it in the earlier parts of the series
then as we got later on because it just
it seemed inappropriate at times it just
there was so much drama in
life-and-death issues that it became a
little more difficult sound came in soul
came in yeah and then I mean he he was
humor as soon as he showed up on the
screen just the way he is you know and I
don't know if you ever noticed his
diploma from his law school as from
America Samoa University American Samoa
University it's like oh I I saw you on
the Sony lot do you remember this when
you were you were in character I
remember every single time I've seen and
I you you tapped me and you're like hey
and I turn around and you're in
character and I like it's it stunned me
a little bit and then I'm realizing it's
kind of hard to not go around with your
head shaved I'm guessing
if you're playing you're playing it you
know a guy with cancer right well you
know I must have I don't know why I was
a big Derek know that this was a
distributors all over the world John
Legend was prefer okay yes I know and
it's so it's on the Sony lot yeah and
you're walking around
yeah because so I'm putting on Walter
White's clothes and glasses and things
like that and and you're kind of there
expecting a little taste of that
character so I put it on and I just I
think I just wanted to scare you you did
what do you want to talk about today oh
gosh well we got so much I mean how can
you not talk about March Madness
oh I mean but I do want to talk about
Power Rangers okay I got some swag for
you guys by the way I like it some Power
Rangers swag look at it that's a cool
hat
I like that is that not a cool hat I
like that because it's just it's just
kind of simple right and then you but
doesn't that look like Wonder Boy for
the national the the bat no I think I
think the lightning bolt was the other
way let's check there could be a
trademark you could get sued here by the
end of this show you're taking a crap on
my apologize I'm just observing that's
all I'm almost not wanting to give you
the the painful but I will give you the
pink anatomically correct it's a big
reveal
okay this here we go look at this here
we go look at that what camera oh and
that one whatever one you want to be on
yeah look at that
okay and I got and I also got a red a
red and blue by our Ranger that is that
awesome now isn't the blue Power Ranger
last name Cranston very good you would
have won a prize a blue Power Ranger is
what I just want yeah you want a blue
power that is nice yes it is when when
the show first came over to the United
States from Japan they had to dub it all
in English and they had to give
American sounding names so they had to
find names and now I was called in I got
a job at Saban doing the the dubbing and
I would come in and do the dubbing and I
but I will always play like the bad guys
you know you will not defeat me I will
and they always do Mirror Mirror before
this is the first step to war or some
crazy bio and they said what is your
strong suit and they said powerful voice
like that's what you're known for they
said that I have a whole article like a
Wikipedia yes you're known for your
powerful voice I don't know nothing else
a great voice alright so power range so
yeah the power rains have come over I
start to do the the dubbing into the
into English and they have to give the
Power Rangers names and now okay this
one's name is Billy
okay what's Billy's last name it's like
[Music]
Cranston's here Billy Cranston fine
Billy crazy so I'm named after the blue
power ranger how about that that's
pretty cool well that's it no the Power
Rangers named after you Brian Power
Ranger alright can you stay yeah yeah
yeah do you want to talk sports oh yeah
come on I and you sent us a text when
you send in your bracket yeah well
reveal that when we return okay yeah
that's a big reveal it's a big reveal
big team oh so come on back alright Dan
Patrick show right after by the way
coming up and about well after the
interview he has one of the great
presentations one of the great gifts
that will ever be able to display in the
man cave I'm not over exaggerating it's
probably a top five movie prop that he
brought in for us so he came bearing
gifts in a variety of ways bryan
cranston the great actor and we start
out the second part of the in
you talking about his new movie the new
Power Rangers movie hits theaters next
Friday that'll be March 24th we were
just talking about it one of our
favorite acting scenes I don't know if
you were acting or not but it was it was
one of our favorite scenes it's Comic
Con and you uh you basically put a guy
in his place who asked you if you had
fun on Breaking Bad poor guy he built up
the courage to ask you a question about
you know actually yeah did I enjoy our
where did you go when you're in
Albuquerque mr. Kraske how did you get
out have any fun well I visited your mom
I know oh man yeah
the truth is I did visit his mom what
sports do you want to talk I know it's
March Madness yeah but are you a big
sports guy I am I am I always have been
you know and born and raised in Los
Angeles and I'm a homer
so everybody there from of course
Dodgers Lakers Kings and the Rams until
they until they deserted me they broke
up with me and left for another city so
they were sleeping with st. Louis for a
long time and then they wanted to come
back and have a relationship again and I
wait wait wait slow down I'm not that
kind of girl
I don't just hop into bed with another
team you know there's a I can smell st.
Louis on you can they win you been think
they could and I think they're heading
in the right direction you know they've
got a young energetic coach who is
supposed to be this phenom you know
there's offensive organized I think yeah
make that and I think I think it's
possible and basically he's got to he's
got to buy into our quarterback and if
he doesn't then we're nowhere I don't
think you would have taken the job if he
he didn't buy into golf right I'm
guessing because you've wasted all those
draft picks or you might have but you
know now you've got to embrace him and
hopefully get your offense in there and
hopefully something magical can happen
as
as sporting as a team ever broke your
heart like you ever cried at a sporting
event well I gotta say that a couple
times when listening to Vin Scully
growing up just hearing his voice call
games and you know the big homerun in
1974 Gibbs the Gibson's homerun 74 that
would have been that was 90 it was 88 88
88 ah Eckersley who I see boy long time
ago you're a lot older than me no
actually I think you're three months
older than me is all right - two months
older
I'm March 7 1956 yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
61 your 60 yeah favorite sports movie is
what well you mentioned the natural or
earlier that was pretty cool I like Bull
Durham a lot I thought that was fun I
was great but you know Susan Sarandon
was Susan Sirdar but I got to tell you
when I was in junior high school I saw
the original Brian song yeah and it made
me cry just wept yeah there was nothing
like that before
is there a sports movie that you would
want to be involved in hmm the renee
Richards story yeah that's right
no actually but in today's society of
doing something like that it's not
people might be interested in renee
Richards story and somebody playing that
role yeah it's not out of the question
it's not out of the question although I
Renee is a well it was a okay pioneer
was a man yes and I think in like an
ophthalmologist doctor yeah and then you
know transitioned into being a female
and then when this was ridiculous
waiting this was unheard of I think
we've stumbled onto something we've done
it if you win the Academy Award for this
role you will thank this show thank I'm
gonna bring the whole show like like the
Oscars
we're talking with a party at dad out
la-la-land
yeah yeah were you there for that no I
wasn't there no I was bet I was bad I'm
doing a movie in Philly at the time
right now so so that's where it was have
you gone to the Academy Awards uh-huh I
was not mind you you don't have to
always go though Trumbull no yeah I
wasn't nominated for Trumbo and that's
the only time I would go is if I'm
nominated or if I'm asked to present
okay you know then I go have you
presented I have not sorry yeah that's
all right that's all right that's right
I've got the Power Rangers coming which
is sure to be an Oscar nomination cuz
cuz the old guard of Hollywood loves
they do power they do yeah they do but
that's the keys you have to do something
that this old guard is going to
appreciate yeah in essence anything that
is big and splashy and commercial a
tentpole movie of the summer you know
that's not gonna happen unless there's
well the special effects of visual
effects or music will we'll get
attention in that area but very very
rarely would an actor or a writer
director get nominated for something but
if you did Breaking Bad is a movie then
then you could win an Academy Award
because there was this transition
no but Breaking Bad would have made a
terrible movie why because you would
have to have truncated all the song I
know that but but you could have made a
movie out of it and you're transitioning
into this Walter White character from a
teacher to you know this drug lord is
that's what they they look at those kind
of things look at those things but but I
think you know I mean it it was supposed
to be a television series because it was
like a book it was like a you a
visualization of a novel because you
take it and every episode was like a new
chapter and you had to take your time
and feel the onion slowly to see oh my
god was it and and if it was a two-hour
movie you'd have to get two things very
quickly to get you an Academy Award okay
well you're not doing a very good job
those Power Rangers listen I think I can
get an Emmy
my guest appearance on the Dan Patrick
show how would you do as hosting this I
think we do pretty well would you guys
the brine Nets wow you got a little you
got a little defensive on that you're
like oh my god all of a sudden was
renamed the guys I'm an actor so I
always have that to fall back on say
when's the last time you've acted when I
said it's Chandler movie ridiculous six
yeah I've been in a ridiculous movies
have I been in I lost track 14 yeah I
think about 13 their films Brian this
was a setup wasn't it I don't know how
many movies have I lost track 14 14 I
played a blanket I played Abe Lincoln
did you play in what you know don't act
like you didn't see it I see now you're
acting Brian yeah you also have a show
on Amazon sneaky PCP it was really it's
cool hey Giovanni Ribisi is awesome in
there yeah man and you play a bad guy I
play a different kind of bad guy I
played the he's a different kind of bad
guys he's a former NYPD guy with a
little dirty so he's a home ground home
grown guy and he's once he wants to feel
his oats and he's a tough guy you know
and so you're talking about Karolina oh
you have this the young lady brunette
the brunette who is your wife have to
approve co-stars know how that works
[Laughter]
I've been I've been married for 28 years
so we're sad we're good so this is like
legalized flirtation this is as close as
I get to having an affair but you've had
nude scenes before I have Julia Roberts
no it's always been by myself did were
you in a wait is that right with Julia
Roberts yeah well on Seinfeld I dated
her yeah yeah we dated on the show but
have you done a nude scene in the movie
I find from all the why about I did a
nude scene in a movie called Larry
Crowne and that was with Julia Roberts I
was married to her yeah I did kind of a
strip scene semi nude in Rock of Ages I
did yeah this there's I'm often without
clothes but julia has a lot of clothes
on you don't
julia was very clothes yes she was
scared she was very nervous you I was
completely naked on top of Julia Roberts
butt and she was like of course I don't
blame her if I was on top of me like
that I go as well but she had anything
on I had a little patch in the front can
I take that back we rolled that I had
this huge patch in the front that was
the only thing I was wearing but you
walk into that scene yeah like it's it's
or do I take off your robe and then you
take off the road no you want me to
describe
I turn off the lights a lighted candle
and turn on some soft music no she's not
giggling she's you know for all I know
she's she's sneaking a peek I don't know
but but I'm naked and she's under the
covers and she's telling Tom Hanks
directed that and she's Tellez trying to
pull the covers off of her saying you
guys are he's trying to make love to you
and you're you know and so you have to
be somewhat unclothed and is he go no no
and so we're pulling down hurt her like
sweatshirt and pulling it down off her
shoulders and further and further and
Tom keeps trying to tug it down and
she's like okay tugging up and then we
figured well why don't we do this why
don't my body cover the parts that we
think would be naked by now and so I was
like so we're positioning my naked body
meanwhile we're worried about you know
showing any kind of cleavage or she's
very shy it's a sweet girl good
but and and very shy and demure a you're
in a movie with Nicole Kidman yeah and
we co-starred in a movie
just go with it it was Aniston and
Kidman yeah I don't think you could did
you come onstage with her I knew a scene
with Kidman and an estate okay
guys am i I'm not making stuff up here
co-starred yeah yeah I'm on just I'm on
stage I co-starred in that scene with
them well I think that's I don't know
why they're giving it Brian ATS
come on the movie is Power Rangers you
play Zordon sword on Zord on the ass or
no sword on not sword ah okay Jordan I
sorta said sword on yeah it hits
theaters next Friday March 24th right
away we got his brackets he's in March
Madness and you did send us pretty do
you have Ryan to tweet his text that he
sent I know was something along the
lines of that's not the answer I want
can I say that word on there well we can
we can bleep it out there's like you
know I got the winner just like take
that beep yes yes why can't you say that
on the air I don't know I just reply
rather you say it to me we said it all
the time on Breaking Bad yeah Aaron Paul
said it constantly but yeah yeah I well
here--here's West Virginia winning at
all West Virginia who else is gonna pick
West Virginia he went to West Virginia
wow so you were kind of excited when you
saw that right yeah man I'm not all
alone on this island who did you have
playing them in the final game I've
Kansas Kansas mm-hmm
yeah and West Virginia I think
Louisville is gonna beat Kansas and I
think it's gonna be North Carolina and
against West Virginia mm-hmm I think
Villanova will be knocked out as well he
plays Zordon in the new Power Rangers
movie and hits theaters next Friday
March 24th thanks for stopping great man
all right thanks let's do it again
let's do it again this time I'm
I really enjoyed coming in the studio
wait you sound surprised well because
I've only been on the phone before I
know I'm gonna be in LA in May first
week of May you are yeah I don't know if
oh no I got I got something to do that
day no I'm just gonna go over to your
house I'm gonna have dinner I was gonna
go see your wife let's call our mutual
friend let's call our mutual friend
we'll go out to lunch or something you
know home talk yes I do yeah yes I do
okay all right son sounds good call Tom
Hanks and we'll go out to lunch mutual
friend thank you Brian thanks dad
appreciate okay so yes I'm shooting a
movie with Kevin Hart and Nicole Kidman
right now called the intouch well and
it's a it's about a guy he cannot
control his bodily movements and so they
create the prop Department created this
little device here and what this is
connected to mana fishing wire is an
ability for me to pull it and I just I'd
get an erection under the sheets just
like so and what's interesting is that
this is anatomically correct
[Laughter]
discoloration I'm not proud of it I also
have a simple hinge this is I actually
use this in the movie and it's like
[Music]
let you keep it
this is yeah so I so we kept this I
would like to actually give this donate
this to the
[Applause]
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience